he was one of the people closest to Tony
and a loyal Soldier unfortunately for
everyone Christopher was also an addict
who drifted in and out of heroin and
alcohol dependency what led to his death
an impaired Christopher was driving Tony
on a highway and drifted into the wrong
lane he swerved and they flipped
multiple times into a ditch Christopher
wasn't wearing a seat belt and was
coughing up blood but still alive
however he begged Tony for help telling
him he'd never pass a drug test when
Tony saw the baby seat for Christopher's
infant daughter pierced by a huge Branch
he realized that Christopher was way too
much of a Loose Cannon as an addict he
was also vulnerable to being flipped by
the feds instead of helping Christopher
Tony pinched his nephew's nose and
suffocated him he died in the season 6
episode Kennedy and Heidi